t-shirts are really not that expensive
whoa okay I'll start from the bottom and
you start from right here I get to this
a little quality right here usually have
that thickness at the bottom well let's
move on to my shirt here well my shirt
is actually high quality you could tell
by the thickness of the bottom rama all
right now that I put my shirt on I think
it might went up on price so I would say
this is like 30 30 bucks I can tell this
shirt is my mom won $15 I say 20 give me
20 give me 20 my shirt cost 20 bucks Hey
look I was in there I was in the right I
was in the right range
I mean t-shirts are not really that
expensive so it got to one pocket in the
front it can't be more like 40 bucks
this shirt costs $95
what makes this shirt feel more
expensive of the texture the thickness
of the shirt I would never spend ninety
seven dollars on this shirt because look
it didn't come with a graphic that shirt
looked like one or two washes going to
be a dingy shirt if I had 24 52 spent on
a shirt I'll do it definitely wouldn't
pay $90 for a t-shirt $24 definitely
wouldn't pay $24 for that t-shirt they
come with an iPhone incoming insurance
that you could go by and train any other
white t-shirts if you go into school you
need uniform or something like that yeah
get you a white t-shirt with your blue
jeans and your blue pants or whatever
you have you get some white vans with
Danny and uh what's his name Daniel